lorsque vous ouvrez l'application Tik
Tok qui est une application
communautaire c'est à dire que Tik Tok
ne produit pas de contenu c'est ce sont
les utilisateurs qui créent des contenus
vous pouvez voir que si vous allez sur
des hashtags
wego par exemple ce mot dièse a été
visionné plus de 400 millions de fois
c'est à dire que vous avez des vidéos
qui défendent ces communautés qui sont
tout à fait en accès libre et partagé
sur l'application Tik Tok donc la
liberté d'expression est totale y
compris pour critiquer tel ou tel
gouvernement sauf en Chine Tic-Toc est
présent dans un très grand nombre de
pays et elle est utilisée par des
communautés y compris des communautés
ouigo je sais que vous êtes très attaché
à ce sujet et qui peuvent s'exprimer
librement sur TikTok pour défendre leurs
droits et parler de leur communauté de
même que vous avez je crois auditionné
Raphaël Glucksman il est pas très
longtemps qui lui raconte aussi sur Tik
Tok sur lequel il fait état de tous ces
discours très critiques sur le
gouvernement ernement chinois et il fait
d'ailleurs des très beaux scores
d'audience donc le rôle le rôle de Tik
Tok si vous me permettez c'est d'être
justement cet espace de liberté
d'expression totale dans le respect
évidemment de la tolérance d'autrui mais
où chacun peut exprimer ses idées sans
aucune forme de censure
vous êtes directeur des affaires
publiques d'une société
dont la maison mère
qui publie 400 millions de messages et
de vidéos je ne sais pas sur les ouigo
Chinois
et
les seuls qui ne peuvent pas voir cela
ce sont les Chinois et vous avez dans le
même groupe Biden skymon la société
l'entreprise douille qui est chinoise et
qui bien évidemment est totalement
censuré il n'y a pas seulement les
ouigos il y a la guerre d'Ukraine etc
est-ce que vous trouvez normal
d'appartenir à un groupe ou la société
qui dit toute la vérité qui dit en tout
cas tout ce que tout le monde a le droit
de dire et qui parle librement n'est pas
accessible en Chine et que dans ce même
groupe il y a une société qui est
pratiquement la même avec un algorithme
qui a été développé au départ
pratiquement identique et qui restait
très largement identique et qui est
totalement censuré par le gouvernement
chinois
ça vous ne protestez pas
moi je suis fier en tout cas
d'appartenir à une entreprise à une
plateforme qui s'appelle Tik Tok et qui
promeut le dialogue des cultures de
toutes les cultures ou la liberté
d'expression est totale j'aurais été
évidemment très mal à l'aise dans le cas
contraire sans doute que je ne serai pas
là mais justement pour précisément Tik
Tok et cette plateforme qui permet
d'opérer alors en respectant les lois en
vigueur dans chaque pays donc il y a
d'autres pays que La Chineuse parfois ça
peut poser problème mais à chaque fois
nous avons défendu la liberté
d'expression nous avons d'ailleurs
publié un engagement en faveur des
droits de l'homme Tik Tok a publié cet
engagement enfin avoir des droits de
l'homme
qui est donc dans la mesure du possible
à chaque fois qu'il y a une difficulté
nous
maintenant et nous défendons la liberté
d'expression et on peut parler de tout
sujet sur Tik Tok y compris de la de la
Chine